there's a moment when you're playing
basketball where everything goes into
autopilot you're doing the same motion
over and over again so mindlessly that
you start to daydream you start to think
of yourself as one of the greatest
players ever oh you can be just as good
if not better than your Idol you cut the
ends off your socks to make an arm
sleeve like Allen Iverson be recruited
by a top school put on the cover of
Sports Illustrated buy your mom a house
buy some jewelry win some jewelry yeah
it was all gonna happen for you except
for the fact that you kind of sucked at
basketball
that doesn't necessarily mean that dream
is dead someone could still hire you to
play basketball if I were you I take
your resume and put basketball
underneath the skill section you never
know maybe some boss of a company or
something is like oh he plays basketball
we could use a guy around here to play
basketball so they get you a hoop and
all day you're just training shots and
everyone's so happy that you're working
they're like oh my god I'm so happy he
works here and like he makes the company
so much money if the money and fame has
gone from playing basketball then why
even play one play you want to lose
again
oh yeah it feels good it's this natural
animal instinct that we have to compete
and when you win you get to have this
moment how great is that